Nos dicen que: "En los últimos años, Granja
Arce ha cosechado alrededor de 1000 manzanas
más que su principal rival de la región, Huerto
Río Grande. Debido al clima frío de este año,
la cosecha de las dos granjas disminuyó
aproximadamente un tercio. Sin embargo, ambas
granjas compensaron parte de este déficit mediante
la compra de cantidades iguales de manzanas en las
granjas de estados vecinos. ¿Qué se puede
decir del número de manzanas disponibles en
cada granja? ¿Tiene una granja mayor cantidad de
manzanas que la otra o tienen la misma cantidad?
¿Cómo lo sabes?". Muy bien. Vamos a resolver esto.
Primero vamos a definir algunas variables. Sea:
A = # de manzanas -igual al número de manzanas- en
Granja Arce -en Granja Arce-, y, por otra parte,
Sea: R = # de manzanas en Huerto Río Grande -R
es igual al número de manzanas en Huerto Río
Grande-. Y leamos otra vez este primer párrafo,
dice: "En los últimos años, Granja Arce ha
cosechado alrededor de 1000 manzanas más que su
principal rival de la región, Huerto Río Grande".
Ok. Podemos decir que A es aproximadamente igual a
R + 1000, o como no sabemos la cantidad exacta,
porque aquí dice "alrededor de 1000 manzanas
más", entonces podemos decir que en un año
normal Granja Arce, que llamamos A, tiene una
mayor cantidad de manzanas que Río Grande,
o R, entonces en un año normal A es mayor que R
aproximadamente por 1000 manzanas. Ahora bien,
también nos dicen que: "Debido al clima frío
de este año, la cosecha de las dos granjas
disminuyó aproximadamente un tercio", así que,
si en un año normal A es menor que R, en este
año tenemos que ambas expresiones disminuyeron
1/3, así que si ambas cosechas disminuyeron 1/3,
esto es lo mismo que decir que ahora tenemos 2/3
de la cantidad anterior. Y vamos a poner aquí un
ejemplo para que se entienda mejor. Si tenemos
x y le restamos 1/3x nos quedaremos con 2/3x,
es decir, disminuir 1/3 de la cantidad inicial
es lo mismo que multiplicar 2/3 por la cantidad
inicial. Ahora bien, si multiplicamos por 2/3 cada
expresión seguiremos teniendo esta desigualdad,
ya que estamos haciendo lo mismo en ambos
lados de la desigualdad, y además estamos
multiplicando por un número positivo. Recuerda que
si multiplicamos esta desigualdad por un número
negativo tendríamos que cambiar la desigualdad.
Así que podemos multiplicar por 2/3 de ambos lados,
y si multiplicamos por 2/3 tenemos que 2/3 de
A seguirá siendo mayor que 2/3 de R. Y podemos
dibujarlo en una recta numérica si queremos. Vamos
a hacerlo. Tal vez esto parezca un poco intuitivo
y si es así, lo siento, pero si no, bueno, no
hace daño aprender. Digamos que tenemos el 0 por
aquí y en un año normal A tiene aproximadamente
1000 manzanas más que R, entonces vamos a decir
que en un año normal A estará por aquí, y tal
vez R esté por acá. Ahora, si tomamos 2/3 de A,
entonces estaremos más o menos, más o menos por
aquí, digamos que esto es 2/3 de A -2/3 de A-,
y ahora ¿dónde colocamos 2/3 de R? Bueno, 2/3
de R estarán más o menos por aquí -2/3 de R-.
Entonces podemos ver que 2/3 de R sigue siendo
menor que 2/3 de A, o 2/3 de A es mayor que 2/3
de R. Ahora, sigamos leyendo: "Sin embargo, ambas
granjas compensaron parte de este déficit mediante
la compra de cantidades iguales de manzanas en
las granjas de estados vecinos", entonces Sea m
la cantidad de manzanas que ambos compraron -Sea
m la cantidad de manzanas que ambos compraron-,
y nos dicen que ambos compraron la misma cantidad
de manzanas, así que podemos sumar m de ambos
lados de la desigualdad y no va a cambiar la
desigualdad. Recuerda que la desigualdad se va
a mantener siempre y cuando sumemos o restemos la
misma cantidad de ambos lados de ella. Entonces,
si sumamos m de ambos lados, tendremos que m +
2/3 de A ˃ 2/3 de R -dos tercios de R- más m.
Esta es la cantidad de manzanas que tiene Granja
Arce después de comprar las manzanas y esta es la
cantidad de manzanas que tiene Huerto Río Grande.
Así que, después de todo lo que hemos hecho
podemos ver que la Granja Arce sigue teniendo más
manzanas, y también podemos verlo gráficamente:
en un año normal la Granja Arce tiene esta
cantidad de manzanas, pero ahora este año tuvo
2/3 de la producción y después compró una cantidad
m de manzanas. Entonces, por ejemplo, si decimos
que m es esta cantidad llegamos hasta acá; y ahora
vamos a copiarla y pegarla para que sea la misma
cantidad m. Entonces Río Grande también compra
la misma cantidad de manzanas m, así que ya está.
Cuando hicimos todo para este año que tuvieron
menos producción y terminaron comprando manzanas,
el Huerto Río Grande tiene esta cantidad de
manzanas, este punto de aquí es 2/3 de R + m;
mientras que la Granja Arce tiene 2/3 de A +
m, que es este valor, por lo tanto, después de
todo esto podemos ver que la Granja Arce sigue
teniendo más manzanas que el Huerto Río Grande.